okay so with the venom vs. x-men part
two I have uploaded the first video yet
I'm kind of recording these back-to-back
but it's kind of crazy because I'll
record the first video the first the
first segment then I'll just be like I
think people are going to have questions
about this or they're gonna have
questions about that or something along
those lines
I try to predict what you guys are going
to ask as best I can and then try to
answer them as we get to the video but
sometimes I just can't sometimes you
guys just throw like these crazy
questions you know like it's kind of
funny like I'll be on Twitter sometimes
and I'll just like tweet out to
emergency awesome and just be like hey
man like you had a really good video and
then somebody will just be like who do
you think would win in a fight and it
just kind of it's just kind of funny to
me but uh but in any event the whole
idea of a vision versus x-men one of the
major things this was designed to do was
to really kind of throw into sharp
relief how much more powerful the
Avengers were than the x-men because
with the idea of the Phoenix 5 the
Phoenix force really just kind of like
amplifies their powers in the extreme
and so it's really kind of a crazy
scenario because on the whole the
Avengers have always been weaker than
the x-men but it was always designed to
be that way the Avengers were always
designed to have powers that were really
more human than anything else I mean you
did have Avengers with exotic abilities
but for the most part like Thor or like
the Incredible Hulk
we're really like the most powerful
Avengers or as with the x-men you had
characters like Vulcan who can
manipulate any form of energy you had
characters like you know Charles Xavier
who was just wildly powerful telepath
you had people like you know Scarlet
Witch for example who was an x-man at
one point who had the ability to warp
reality I mean you have Franklin
Richards who's a mutant that can warp
reality I mean you have all different
kinds of characters with these extreme
levels of powers and so because of that
the x-men and the mutant population were
always designed to be stronger now I
wouldn't go as far as to say this was
Marvel just kind of being like did the
Avengers suck yeah I don't really think
that was the case I think we really just
kind of designed to show us how powerful
a group of x-men can be with the
entirety of the Phoenix force at their
disposal and so really it's in a lot of
ways it's just kind of like these
hit-and-run tactics the Avengers really
have no choice here now the other half
of this is the idea that the Avengers
are trying to think about it from a
technological standpoint but the Phoenix
force is life energy there's really no
technology behind it the Phoenix force
is not like a series of Nana
so they're just like running around and
immerse themselves in flame and take on
the form of Phoenix it's not that way
it's the representation of life energy
they're basically dealing with energy
forces but the adventures don't really
have very many people on their side who
can deal with that the most powerful to
beings they have at the moment right now
in the Avengers roster is Scarlet Witch
and Doctor Strange and their power only
goes so far remember doctor Strange's
power was nerfed already I mean you had
that whole story where you had classic
Doctor Strange you could do virtually
anything but he lost his gift from the
vishanti who gave him the various magics
that he could use he lost his connection
with them when he refused to fight
alongside them in a war in the
dimensional plane and so once he
regained his powers he only regained a
fraction of the power he used to have as
though he's not nearly as powerful as it
used to be otherwise he could just end
this right now he could just eliminate
the Phoenix force and it would just be
done and that would be it and so because
of that there's a lot of folks here you
know on the Avengers side who are
dealing with it as best they can but
they're just woefully outmatched they're
just not quite capable and that's why we
end up seeing things like Doctor Strange
you know grabbing these little items
like the enchantments of ikon that's why
we have people like Black Panthers
saying we have to consult vasta Pepa god
they're reaching for whatever they can
they're just grasping at straws to try
to find a way to defeat the Phoenix fund
and it really shows the desperation of
the Avengers where they are right now
because they really don't have a choice
they're really doing the best they can
with what they have and that's really
about it now in terms of the
manipulative nature of Emma Frost this
really comes to fruition with regards to
Namor the Submariner now the implication
here is it the two of them are having an
affair but the two of them are basically
sleeping together now this is really
just kind of given to us through the
fact that they share a kiss that that
kind of thing but Emma Frost also says
look you know I know where they took one
of our own I know where they took
transonic a member of our group and
she's being kept in Wakanda now the
reason why this is Emma Frost being so
manipulative is because of the fact that
she's basically going to lead to name
Wars destruction I really not to death
per se but him losing his portion of the
Phoenix force but Emma Frost has always
been this way Emma Frost has always been
manipulative going all the way back to
like you know really even before Grant
Morrison's time on new x-men
really during Grant Morrison's time and
Chuck Dixon's time on new x-men when
Jean Grey walked in on a psychic affair
between Cyclops and Emma which kind of
led to Jean Grey basically being forced
out of the pick
and Emma Frost and Cyclops pairing up
the factor of Eames here that Emma's
always been that way now for a lot of
especially women readers that was a
refreshing thing because I looked at her
as like an empowered chick right like
she does whatever she needs to do in
order to achieve her goal but the
downside of this was that it made her
look very vindictive and it made her
look very petty and so it really kind of
took away from her accomplishment
because of the road she took to get
there
but the fact remains that with regards
to the whole you know tension between
Black Panther and name with a submariner
this comes by way of the fact that name
or attached Wakanda now it's not as
though he just does this blindly I mean
he does to a degree but Emma Frost was
preying on the desire of name work to
engage in conflict and engage in work
name has always been a very heavy-handed
character when it came to like dealing
with enemies in terms of you know Marvel
Comics if somebody just straight across
Atlantis or even if they accidentally
harm somebody from Atlantis never the
Submariner was like film in prison and
kill him and that was it it that's just
the way it was there either there were
no if ands or buts
you know you harm somebody from Atlantis
and you were done with all your living
according to the name where the
Submariner this is an extension of that
belief system within almost infinite
amount of power and so with the kind of
ability that he possesses he looks at
cyclops as a failure in a lot of ways
because what Namor says is this is war
you're not with us you're against us and
if you're against us you're in the way
you chose your side and you knew what
was coming
sorry about your luck that's really just
kind of the stance if he takes and so
him attacking Wakanda is the most
natural progression that was character
now the other half of this brings into
the idea Kunlun now really mad fractions
is kind of like bringing some of the
stuff that he did with regards to iron
fist into the equation which is one of
the reasons why we covered the run of
iron fist but there was a point in the
history of Kunlun when one of the iron
fist long before Danny ran had basically
faced face against and staved off
somebody who basically became a host for
the Phoenix force now there isn't a
whole lot of expansion given there it's
basically the same this is one of the
things that one of the many iron fists
throughout the history of the iron fist
mantle have done just one of the
multitude of things that they've
achieved but what it does is it brings
Kunlun in because it means they have
experience with the Phoenix none of them
have become a Phoenix entity but they
have experience with it on how to train
their their iron fist to cope with the
Phoenix force now at the end of the day
Danny ran the iron fist going against
any one of the Phoenix five is like
throwing a rock at a train I mean it's
not
anything I mean it's comedic at best and
all he can really do is just buy time
and even then it's seconds maybe I mean
he just doesn't stand a chance the Iron
Fist is just nowhere near powerful
enough but what this does do is it
grants a reprieve for Hope Summers will
reign and a handful of others to
basically retreat and then use Kunlun as
a base of operations because remember
Kunlun is in another dimension so you
literally have to cross the dimensional
barrier to get to coonley it's like that
phrase from from Pirates of the
Caribbean it's a place that cannot be
found except by those who already know
where it is
but the fact remains here that with
regards to what conduct then with the
submariners actions here just lay waste
to the city I mean he basically musters
all of his forces and just brings them
to bear onto Wakanda and just eradicate
the entirety of the city killing tons of
people in the process now this creates a
blood of blood vendetta between a black
panther and name of the Submariner and
so when we get to Hickman's Avengers in
New Avengers and we start referencing
things like why it is a Black Panther
hates name of the Submariner so much we
will point back to this story so you
guys can see what it is that we're
talking about now with regards to name
of the Submariner effectively being
defeated he loses his portion of the
Phoenix force but what we end up finding
out here is that when one member of the
Phoenix 5 loses their their connection
to the Phoenix force the remainder of
the Phoenix force well I guess that
portion spreads throughout the remainder
of those individuals who were bonded to
the Phoenix and so because of this what
it does is it sets the seeds for a civil
war between the remainder of the Phoenix
5 really the Phoenix for now because
they're all imbued with name of the
submariners powers that's what the idea
in all of their minds are the idea in
the mind of Cyclops on the mind of Emma
Frost the mind of Colossus the mind of
Illyana Rasputin is if everybody else
dies everybody else loses their
connection they'll basically maintain
the totality of the Phoenix force and so
what it does is just kind of make this
race to bring all the others down so
because of this we end up picking up
like eight days after the you know
basically the fall of name with a
submariner and what we end up finding
out here is that using Kunlun as a base
of operations the Avengers are launching
these attacks to basically go into the
main Marvel Universe grab what other
members of The Avengers they can and
bring them back and so really the
Phoenix 5 are really I guess the Phoenix
4 at this point I just kind of taken
over the earth I mean there's really no
way for the Avengers to stand on their
own now in the background of all this
hope so
murrs it's basically being trained in a
lot of the various forms of mysticism
and martial arts available to Kunlun now
the funny thing about that is it like
kung fu is not going to do her any good
but the idea of her being training kung
fu isn't about like kicks and punches
and self-defense
it's about her honing her soul coming to
grips with who she is what she's about
and getting a better understanding of
herself and so because of that it makes
your mo more in tune with her own powers
gives her kind of like a spiritual peace
which in turn will give her better
access and a better understanding of her
own powers and make her a more
formidable because in the end it all
really comes down to her I mean right
now the Avengers are in shambles I mean
whether is Captain Britain which he
never really mattered like Scarlet Witch
ant-man Red Hulk she-hulk Wolverine I
mean they're all basically just being
completely crushed with regards to you
know Tony Stark everybody's doing all
the research they can but in the end it
doesn't matter it doesn't make a
difference they're all basically being
taken down so what we end up doing is
joining the Avengers you know is it
basically make this you know another
campaign into the main Marvel Universe
but we end up finding that Illyana
Rasputin uses her powers to basically
command the forces of limbo and
essentially brings in hell on earth now
in the realm of Marvel Comics limbo is
one of a multitude of dimensions that
are basically held I mean you have a lot
of those like you actually have the
dimension of health which is where
Mephisto hangs out at Emma Sisto is
basically the devil in Marvel Comics but
there's a lot of dimensions that are
filled with like fire and brimstone and
demons and monsters and different things
like that but limbo is a dimension that
Illyana Rasputin has total control on
and calls her own she's basically queen
of that realm and so because of that
when she brings it over to earth most of
the Avengers were able to get out in
time but spider-man is really kind of
like the last man left you know offering
what little solace II can offering what
little safety you can while the Avengers
rescue those who have been taken by the
rest of the Phoenix force and so what is
up happening is spider-man actually
manipulates the two of them and this is
one of the coolest things here because
in the renew your vows story from Secret
Wars one of the things that Marvel
established is that Spiderman tells
jokes for the purpose of throwing off
his enemies whereas enemies are taking
the situation seriously when it seems
like spider-man's not taking them
seriously it throws them off it keeps
them off-guard knocks them off balance
because they don't know what to expect
it's like the classic Bruce Lee method
of fighting right I mean you know don't
clench your fists until the moment of
impact dance around always be on the
move
spider-man is much the same way in terms
of how he conducts himself but the way
he does this is he preys on his
knowledge of the defeat of name of the
Submariner and begins talking to Illyana
Rasputin and Colossus innovating saying
you guys are brother and sister you guys
really want to fight each other I mean
why would you want to find each other
because if one of you Falls the other
will get the oh that person's powered
and so what he does if you basically
Lance this little thought in their brain
that if Colossus takes out magic or if
magic takes out Colossus they'll gain
the others power and so at this point
it's would just kind of feeding on their
bloodlust feeding on their on their
corruption and just kind of going from
there just letting nature take its
course and so things unfold exactly as
you would expect it to
when Illyana Rasputin and Colossus end
up fighting one another and it
ultimately results in both of them being
defeated and remainder of their power
spreading to Emma Frost and Cyclops and
so because of this you know Cyclops
effectively locates Kunlun breaks into
it with the intention of grabbing Hope
Summers and bringing her back and so
because of the stance that people like
Emma Frost are taking where she's
basically forcing mutants that are in
Utopia into subservience because Cyclops
is becoming so extreme and willing to
kill anyone who gets in his way
ultimately magneto begins to see himself
in the two of them and that's what's so
ironic here about this one of reasons
why Magneto's character was so cool
during Avengers vs. x-men it's because
how we see Cyclops and Emma Frost
depicted here this is 1990s magneto now
this is business 1980s 1970s magneto the
guy who will do whatever it takes in
order to keep mutants safe even if it
means crushing and conquering the world
and so because of this magneto does the
only thing he can do
he basically walks out into the open and
contacts Charles Xavier and says we need
your help on this now Xavier was well
aware of what was going on up to this
point but he had always kind of been
hands-off he had always sort of stayed
away from everything that was going on
somewhat because of the fact that in his
mind there had to be a peaceful way to
bring Cyclops back and he was really
just kind of biding his time and waiting
for that moment to talk Cyclops down and
bring him back to his normal self before
he was too far corrupted from the
Phoenix's power but at the end of the
day we also get a better understanding
of Hope Summers powers and the sense
that Hope Summers can basically
duplicate the powers of others that
whenever she's in a close proximity of
her of a person she can copy their
abilities now the cool thing about this
is that she can do it with more than one
so she's like Peter Petrelli from hero
season 1 before they nerfed his
character
screwed them up and so because of that
she's basically a character who's just a
living copycat of anybody else's powers
which makes her wildly powerful because
imagine that she was standing in close
proximity to Emma Frost and Colossus
Scarlet Witch or something like that
she'd have all three of their powers she
could use Emma Frost telepathy
she could use scarlet witch's
reality-warping powers and she would
have the organic metal skin of Colossus
it's kind of crazy what is that she can
do and so what we end up dealing is to
basically jump back over to Captain
America and this is really the Avengers
in their most desperate hour because
what we do is we join Captain America
out in the middle of nowhere and Captain
America is just beseeching some unknown
person simply saying look we've
exhausted every option we need every
ounce of help that we can get I would
not come here unless it was absolutely
necessary but I absolutely need your
help will you help me you have to have
been seen what was going on with the
Avengers in the x-men will you help me
with this conflict and we ultimately end
up finding out the person that Captain
America is talking to is the Incredible
Hulk now this is so cool and the reason
why is because of the fact that after
after Greg Cox run we ended up getting
the Incredible Hulk by Jason Aaron but
basically he just went into like a
period of self-imposed exile he just
disappeared off the face of the planet
or however long he just stayed hidden
from everybody and so with the
Incredible Hulk being brought in here
this brings in a massive powerhouse at
the same time we also end up joining or
traveling to Wisconsin and joining rode
and rogue basically joins the Avengers
and what we end up finding out here is
that Charles Xavier has effectively been
going alongside the Avengers and
mustering all these forces that are
Avengers and x-men related and so what
this is designed to do is to show us
that people have basically walked away
from Cyclops and Emma Frost they've lost
faith in them they've lost faith in
their mission and that's really where it
is that Cyclops and like magneto began
to stray that's where they really began
to kind of part ways it's because
historically speaking magneto was always
mutants first if there's any group that
can count on me to to ensure their
safety it will always be mutants
everybody else is second best Cyclops
initially presented himself this way and
that's why so many beatings rally to his
caused is because he showed up and said
look we're going to turn this mutant
island of utopia we're going to turn
into a refuge
mutants but then end up going you know
from being this enlightened dictatorship
to turning into this totalitarian
power-hungry regime and that's when
mutants began to walk away especially
those individuals who were looking at
the at the avengers and saying look we
fought as friends once we'd like to
fight as friends again because Cyclops
and Emma Frost are beyond the point of
control and so because of this we end up
joining Xavier kind of entering into
cyclopses mind and this is cool because
it's a battle being fought on two fronts
on one side it is Xavier in the mind of
Cyclops more or less kind of talking to
them offering some measure of
distraction on the outside it is all the
Avengers in these x-men facing off
against Cyclops so it's really kind of
cool because it's just like Cyclops
versus everyone and it's amazing to see
because at the end of the day Emma Frost
and Cyclops are the last who's standing
and try as they might the Avengers just
don't have the power to take both these
guys out on their own because they're
just so strong they're just so capable
and so because of this you know in this
moment of desperation in this hour of
basically realizing he needs more power
Cyclops
turns against Emma Frost and in doing so
basically incapacitate her and steals
her portion of the Phoenix force which
basically transforms him into Dark
Phoenix now again this is the crazy
thing here is because this shows us how
far Cyclops has fallen and this was
designed for the purpose of ushering in
Cyclops
into a new era of taking Cyclops in a
new direction to where he would be more
extreme who had become like the classic
Magneto but in a more extreme capacity
so for those of you guys who were
reading the stories were online reading
different articles about how Cyclops has
basically quote-unquote gone evil this
is the story that set the stage for that
but the first act he does with the
totality of the Phoenix forces powers is
kill Charles Xavier and this was really
like him crossing a line that he can't
come back from now the other half of
this is that in some ways it is Marvel
giving Cyclops an out is basically
Marvel saying this is what happens when
a person becomes fully imbued with the
power of the Phoenix force they don't
know how to control it they fall down
the path of darkness because it's so
much power that they almost go
completely insane and in some cases when
they become dark Phoenix they do lose
their minds in their entirety and so
this is really just like a last-ditch
effort by everyone
how to stave off and try to end the
power of cyclops once and for all and so
what is up happening here is Hope
Summers and Scarlet Witch effectively
team up to brief Cyclops down now the
cool thing about this is that it's also
this idea that Cyclops recognizes how
far it is that he's falling and it's
really him just kind of recollecting on
his own memories you know going back and
looking at the times that he and
Wolverine fought together looking at the
times that he was a student of Xavier
the death of Jean Grey you know these
are moment that he looks back on and he
begins to realize that he's effectively
losing himself but the problem is that
what's happening to Cyclops now is
exactly what happened to Jean Grey
corrupted by power not able to control
it the Phoenix force takes on a life of
its own and so using a moment of
distraction post summers just kind of
immerses you know through this fire
looking like Jean Grey but in this brief
second she takes the moment alongside
alongside Scarlet Witch to basically
take out Cyclops to beat him and then
absorb the entirety of the Phoenix now
the implication seems to be here that
the Phoenix was always trying to find
its way back to Hope Summers and he was
just kind of doing so and so it seems
like there was some measure of personal
control by Cyclops over the Phoenix that
he basically wouldn't let the Phoenix
leave that seems to kind of be what's
happening here the problem is that
witness into the story it just wraps up
just like that it wraps up so fast and
there's really not much in the way of a
great ending here because it's just
really kind of like well where do we go
from here and what is up happening
it's Hope Summers having been perfectly
in tune with the Phoenix force becomes
the white Phoenix of the crown the
problem with this and the reason why it
doesn't make any sense is because Jean
Grey was always billed to be the perfect
host for the Phoenix which is why she
became the white Phoenix of the crown
she and the Phoenix force were
effectively one in the same she was born
to be a host for the Phoenix when she
basically died quote-unquote and joined
the Phoenix force and became the white
Phoenix to the crown she was going to be
the one singular being that basically
fixes what's broken in the universe
whatever that happens to me whatever
Marvel wants it to mean in any
particular point in time with Hope
Summers becoming the white Phoenix of
the crown and Jean Grey nowhere in sight
the question has to be asked what
happened to Jean but before we even get
an answer to that question before we
ever find out what happens
Scarlet Witch more or less just kind of
approaches Hope Summers and says no you
are never really meant to have the
Phoenix force and she simply says no
more Phoenix and the Phoenix force is
destroyed and that's it and so it's a
very anticlimactic and lackluster ending
to what was otherwise an insanely great
story but what comes out of the death of
the Phoenix force more or less is
basically this emergence of mutants all
over the world mutant powers begin
cropping up and popping back up all over
again so what's the story really begins
to wind down once all basically begins
to come to a close Cyclops is
effectively taking taken prisoner by the
Avengers because of the fact that he had
killed Charles Xavier you know he's
taken prisoner he's basically held in
stasis but it sets the stage for him to
effectively break out and then
eventually go on to you know lead his
own group of x-men or you know more of
like a rogue group and so on and then of
course Hope Summers just kind of takes
off into the sky to find her own place
but again it's not the best ending I was
really disappointed me endings of the
story because I kind of felt like
Marvell wrote themselves into a hole and
didn't know how to get out but in any
event uh if you guys are new here to
come as explained make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
rock or if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you guys Leonard please
[Music]
[Applause]